we got the story
from timcast.com
chicago mayor lori lightfoot warns
unvaccinated residents your time is up
and she said it just like that too
she said we didn't want to get to this
point actually i should read it like
lori lightfoot because she's beetlejuice
touchy talks like this we didn't want it
to get to this point but uh given the
situation we find ourselves in we have
no choice beginning january 3rd you must
show proof you are fully vast 200 bars i
haven't seen that moving a really long
time by the way
i don't know if i'm doing a good michael
keaton
she says tantra bars restaurants fitness
centers and entertainment and
recreational venues where food and drink
are served but the best part was when
she said where is it do we even have it
on here here we go to put it simply if
you have been living vaccine free your
time is up if you wish to live life as
with the ease to do the things you love
you must be vast this health order may
pose an inconvenience to the
unvaccinated and in fact it is
inconvenient by design i had to read it
like a villain yeah because that was one
of the most villainous
like
statements on vaccine mandates from any
executive i don't know that one from
biden was pretty bad they're like if you
don't get vaccinated you face a long
dark cold winter and you're going to
overwhelm the hospitals and basically
you're going to die it i i don't i don't
yes it was bad but i don't agree right
when i when i saw so that was from
zientz or whatever the coronavirus task
force guy on biden's administration he
said the unvaxed can be expecting a
winter of death and you know like
suffering or whatever because you'll
overwhelm the hospitals but that's more
like what you know i imagine that as if
i was watching a movie
there's like a hooded figure issuing
like a prophetic warning and like
shaking a bony finger you will face
death
and that's not the real villain but this
one she's like if you've been living
vaccine free your time is up that's like
skeletor straight up being like i'll get
you he-man you know like not like just
like a warning you know they're just
gonna try to make your life as miserable
as possible he said it
bill de blasio was like we're going to
take away your life liberty and pursuit
of happiness unless you inject yourself
with this you know this medication you
want liberty do what we say yeah but you
won't even get liberty if you do it
that's the crazy thing no not at all and
in fact the dc area d much uh sorry
washington dc just came out with its own
vax mandate today as a matter of fact
and in there it gave a definition of
vaccinated you know and it's like two
shots
you're only one shot if you're a kid two
shots if you're adult of course that's
gonna change there's no liberty there
you're gonna just keep having to get the
shot but i'm faced with now like i'm
literally i can't go to any restaurants
in dc you gotta be good you gotta move i
gotta move i wish the word that easy i'm
divorced it's been a long time it's been
12 years we've been divorced the kids
are here i'm not you know i have two
choices i can either abandon my kids or
i can kidnap them either way these are
two you know obviously i can't do either
one of those so i'm i'm stuck right and
uh you know i wish people would
understand that when they come at me
about the vax thing it's like also i
have split custody and this is the thing
divorce families are facing all across
the country where the parents don't
agree on what to do about the vaccine
well now you now there's no question
your kids have to be faxed period
i mean
they're making it that way it used to be
you know so we had that conversation
about you know your kids want to do
sports and then we got in that debate
now it doesn't even matter that's not
even a question anymore now it's i there
there's not going to be any legal
defense there there will be
but i'll say this first and foremost
it's one thing to be like if i want my
kids to play sports they got to get the
vaccine because of these rules now
they're just going to be like if you
want your kid to go to a restaurant if
you go to a gym to go to the schools to
do any of that stuff they have to be
back so it's either they stay at home
all day or they get the vaccine so i
think that when it comes to a court
like a court argument where you're
saying you don't you know want your kids
yeah there's no choice but they're just
going to judge boom done exactly yeah so
i i literally have no choice and people
people don't like nuance the trolls
don't like any nuance and they give me a
hard time about our conversation that we
had a couple of months ago and i'm just
faced with the fact that i'm no longer
and my i'm no longer going to be able to
go to restaurants museum bars nightclubs
theaters you know music venues whatever
and even in the adjacent counties
montgomery county arlington county
they're going to be doing the same thing
montgomery county just announced it i'm
never going to be able to go to the
metropolitan museum of art ever again in
new york city i'm like being deleted out
of society because i'm a strong healthy
you know man that has maybe i think i've
had it before i remember march 2020
after cpac man everybody was sick after
yeah well then people got it at cbec
yeah i'm going to chicago and we're
leaving uh tomorrow at some point and
this is probably the last time i'll ever
go to chicago no joke no
i feel fortunate that i've been able to
travel the world already right because
so many people can't but uh and the the
response from the people in the cult are
just like why don't you just
do as you're told and i'm like i because
i don't agree with it whether whether
you're vaccinated or not i think the
mandates are absolutely wrong in austria
they're bringing out inspectors to go
track people down and find them
so what i think is going to happen is
what chicago is basically saying is for
the foreseeable future until we deem it
safe it's never gonna be safe not ever
ever i uh i do have tsa pre so i don't
have to take my shoes off when i go on
the airlines but i still watch all those
people go through the line taking off
their shoes taking their laptops out of
their back all these things it's not
that that is never going to change i
suspect the masks on the airplane
probably never going to change oh yeah i
mean who was it someone already came out
and said they should be permanent was it
fouchy i think it was yeah i think fauci
was like everybody should wear masks
forever right and despite the fact that
two ceos of the airlines came out and
talked about how the air filters inside
those planes make for like the cleanest
possible air you could ever be in
possibly like takes out 99 of any
possible covid uh you know infectious
particles and whatnot yeah these things
are never going to change
the new society we have to deal with you
know how they have those when you're in
the plane they have the the fan you can
unscrew the thing and it blows the air
out yeah so have you ever sat next to
someone on a plane who farts a lot
it happens right because
what happens is there's le there's lower
it's a lower pressure in a higher
altitude
so the plane is pressurized science no
it is check it out the plane is the
plane is pressurized
but it's still lower pressure than you
would be on the ground and so the gas in
your body expands and makes it more
likely for you to fart well i've
traveled so much man i'll let you in on
a tip many people may already know this
if you travel but i used to fly twice a
week so what i would do is i would open
the vent and have the the fan blow down
to my right side to create a barrier and
so when the fart would come out the air
would hit it and push it away you think
i'm kidding it works brilliant it works
and so i bring this up because
it should be true for anything including
you know the droplets yeah if you turn
the fan on you have it below next to you
and you got a little wind barrier
pushing away the air and it pulls in air
from other directions so not not only
that but you you're right you got the
filters in these in these airplanes they
don't care man one thing i've noticed
i've been traveling so much as well i've
got like executive platinum pro status
on american now
nobody gives a crap about wearing masks
in the airport i have not been wearing a
mask in any airport i don't wear one
until i get to the point of going on to
the into the gate right down into the
airplane nobody cares i've seen people
walk up with no mask on they don't say
they just hand them a mask don't say
anything the only time that they require
it is on the plane you know what not
even all the time then they they do
require it in airports but there's no
enforcement for the most none like a tsa
agent is going to walk up isn't going to
walk up to you randomly and be like put
on the most conservative no one says
anything no one says anything in that
plane though right and then all of a
sudden they're like federal law says
there's no federal law no it's a trick
they're doing there's a federal law that
grants the president right to issue
executive orders and the president
issued an executive order and now
they're claiming a federal license
right and this is this is uh emblematic
of the problem of the bureaucratic state
where they create these vague laws and
then they empower this whole um
administrative state to then then
administer the laws and whatever the way
they see fit and then they they issue
these rules these mandates and then the
the courts will adjudicate them and
effectively it becomes law at that point
but you have basically an army of
technocrats deciding the way that we
have to live our lives today and it's
out of the power of the legislature why
hasn't congress sat down and actually
debated these very things on the floor
of congress and decided whether or not
the people want to have that those times
have come and gone
like that democracy yeah yeah republican
you see the babylon b article it was
like in in
it was like it was like a terrible blow
for democracy majority representatives
made a decision for country right
they're blaming it all on the one west
virginia senator and it's like well what
about the other like 50 guys that didn't
vote for it as well it's ridiculous yeah
and you know what kudos to that guy for
for holding his ground and making his
decision he's under a lot of pressure i
don't understand why he still caucuses
with the democrats he doesn't vote with
that considering going independent
independent he should he should
uh and the fact that they try to lay it
all on him is just a ridiculous cop-out
it's it's part of their the alinsky
strategy of isolating targets and like
funneling all of the energy onto them
and hopefully making it personal and
hopefully getting them to crack uh it's
in the book rules for rules for radicals
and they do it they they isolate people
they target them
hell i've seen people do that in my
personal life we got it i found it from
babylon b it says in stunning blow to
democracy legislation decided by
majority of elected representatives oh
my gosh i love it
because they keep saying like how come
one man is stopping us and it's like
it's 51 senators
you're insane in a stunning blow
basically uh democracy works in action a
majority of elected representatives deny
the passage of the bill wow somebody
somebody just super chatted saying that
they were denied seeing their kids
because by a judge because they're not
vaccinated i i'm sorry to hear that for
you dude i i i i i've heard this a
number of times we've seen court orders
where parents were not allowed to see
their own children because of the vax
thing i don't know
i don't know if we're gonna win this one
the backs
yeah i think the vaccine mandates will
become law
and people will get their routine
injections
and they're not you know give it give it
five years and no one's gonna even
question it and the reason is i think
you've got cult members and cowards and
that makes up the bulk of what this
country is
so i can't remember who well first there
was clifton duncan who had an amazing
tweet he said something the effect of my
uh disdain for covidiets has been you
know superseded by my my my disdain for
those who know something is wrong and
refuse to speak up yeah
so
you know every single person who
watched this
in in in the beginning and said i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna say anything i'm not
gonna put any risks to myself and are
now suffering the consequences i mean
it's too late the time to speak up was a
while ago now that chicago and dc and
other places are rolling these things
out and we saw what happened in new york
they will comply regular people will
drop to their knees to fellate the state
with a smile on their face no maybe not
a smile on their face maybe they'll be
crying while they do it but like let's
be real
they're going to do it and then what
that means is
there will be outliers there will be um
people who refuse to participate a lot
some of these people who oppose many of
them who oppose the mandates are
vaccinated and these people will find
themselves
in the woods
you know
or you know the the metaphorical woods
right you can still go to the grocery
store
you can still walk around on the streets
you think they're really going to come
after groceries
100
yes in austria it's a mandate period
even in your own home you must be
vaccinated so they're hiring inspectors
to do research and track people down and
then issue them a 3 600 euro fine every
quarter if they do not get vaccinated
well in dc not only now can they issue
you a fine but they can revoke your
business and driver's licenses they
can't do it they do it and people drop
to their knees and say i will do
anything you say because they're losers
they're gonna
look take my driver's license take my
business license i will not comply i'm
not complying i'm never going to comply
period end of story it would be nice if
we could like make maybe if it happens
to me we could file a lawsuit and try to
fight this but there's absolutely no way
at this point because look it's the more
they tell me i have to do it the less i
am interested in replying
yes exactly i will not ever comply not
you know what the issue is
i will not bend the knee to
slimy
cultists
you can show me all the science in the
world and i'm going to say when the evil
people are beating it's like this
imagine you've got um
a despotic king and he's evil as evil
can be and they beat and torture and
maim and dwells really awful stuff and
then they say we've we we are going to
mandate everyone eat these delicious
pomegranates i'd be like you can't make
me do anything i don't care right i like
pomegranates right you know i mean i
think vaccines are great right but the
state taking this power it's only going
to get substantially worse
so for me it's like
it's very obvious
if
this is the path we're on
you can only imagine how insane it will
be a year from now because you think
about what the the past two years have
been like first it was two weeks then it
was just wear a mask we've seen the
memes it's just this it's just this
eventually you see in australia they're
rounding they're rounding people up and
putting them in camps and they're
justifying it and i'll tell you how
scary it is yeah when claire lehman of
quillette
is one of the cheerleaders
for arresting people without due process
and bringing them to a camp and saying
it's normal
yo we are in trouble man how what is her
deal dude because she was posting
instagram pictures from like i guess the
olympic team like stayed there briefly
and saying like this is who's staying
there timmy
hot babes that's who was staying there
man don't you want to be there with the
hot babies do you remember when there
was a hot minute when colette was like
oh right on point right on the cutting
edge like really doing the thing that
they're supposed to do
really saying the right things doing
like actual science and thinking about
it and reporting on real anti-woke stuff
and then now she's like
it's just the olympic team man don't
worry about it well she was making it
seem like it was all hot babes right
yeah when it was actually just one
propaganda moment from a year ago or
whatever right exactly so they have
these um do you think she did that
unwittingly or is she an agent now
i think she's scared
that the state will will take everything
away from her
and she's in this position where she's
not that famous but she's famous enough
and she knows it she knows her option is
stand on principle and be persecuted or
get on your knees inflate the state and
at least you'll you'll be you'll be
you'll be you'll be fed you regularly
look all this does is confirm to me that
what we're doing in the liminal order
even makes more sense we're building an
independent network separate from the
institutions we're finding ways to do
our business with each other invest in
each other's companies all this drama
that's going on around me right now i
literally could not give one single f
because all we're doing right now is
like building businesses that are going
to change the world we're building ways
that people can get independent access
and direct access to beef for example
look up modern tea man he's working on
getting away to get direct access from
the consumers to the beef producers so
we can cut out the middlemen we're
trying to find all kinds of solve
education problem communications
problems because you're gonna have to
get meaning safety security
entertainment culture and arts all from
independent networks instead of the
institutions because institutions want
you
fat sick jailed or you know tied to your
desk in debt for the rest of your life
that's what they i think there's a lot
of people who are choosing
they know it's wrong they know what's
going on is wrong and they're lying to
themselves and just going along with it
because
you know people are um tribal beings so
there's like this dude i know who uh
he's tweeting about how he's like got
the third shot and i was like you get in
the fourth
yep
and i'm like in the fifth and the six
and they're like it's endemic it's gonna
be like a flu shot and i'm like yeah i
know but you never got a flu shot before
dude like i know you right and all of a
sudden you're just accepting these these
this this new normal i never got a flu
shot ever i never get the flu shots but
i do the kid i got one but i do have the
measles mumping rubella yeah i do have
the polio pertussis all the time i got
i've got more vaccines than the average
person substantially i've talked about
before yeah i was traveling so they give
you all these crazy different shots yeah
and i've i received the fluke
it makes sense you're going to places
where you can catch the disease just by
standing there and it makes you really
super sick and concerned i'll tell you
what i'm excited about man we
we put in the down payment the deposit
for the new free damastan building yeah
and then we had the construction crew
come out and we drew up the the general
design of it
it's going to be amazing it's going to
be i think
it might it i think it's going to be 36
feet at the at the peak and it's going
to be 25 foot walls 75 feet by 100 feet
and then we're building the new studio
it's going to be slightly bigger than
the room we're in the room we're in now
is about uh 15 by 30 15 by 32 i think
actually
and the the one we're building is going
to be 25 by 40. dang so we're gonna have
a much bigger room and it's gonna have
uh it's gonna have one big glass window
overlooking the the work facility it's
going to be amazing and so what we're
doing there is for one we're going into
a place where we don't have to worry
about any of this stuff and maybe maybe
it's bad that you know we retreat or
whatever but man
i was in we were in the new jersey area
we were trying to buy a building and
everything started to fall apart when
covet happened and then ultimately we
decided
you know we we could barely go out
because they had to stay at home orders
and so
it wasn't back then it was interesting
because no one was forcing you to stay
home it was just like we were kind of
doing it because we're like okay what
else do we do
well there was nowhere to go
yeah yeah everything was closed down
yeah and so we would just sit around but
we had a backyard we had a fire pit ian
would make fires and we'd hang out big
skate park i remember seeing that i
remember seeing that the first time i
was like
it wasn't it wasn't super big it was
like it was like 15 feet by 60 feet or
something like that
i guess that's no not 60 feet
actually yeah maybe it no maybe it was
50 feet it was 50 feet so it was like a
big concrete platform so we were able to
exercise we were able to barbecue and
have fires but ultimately i was like
dude this stuff's getting worse
you know like we need to get out of here
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you